we are here at the National Museum of
play in Rochester New York where they
have one of the world's most amazing
collections of toys and games and yes
video games Atari by design this is a
great example of how when we get a
collection you're not just getting it
just to keep it locked up somewhere to
hoard it well you want to make it
available these things just don't
magically appear and they're part of a
long process of design attestations yep
and so what we can do is show people
that in here and give them a chance to
play the game - I have to point out you
have a gotcha machine I don't think I've
seen one of these in real life it's a
simple maze game right that they in some
ways that predecessor of pac-man all
right we've got more I see you have a
Street Fighter machine I almost want to
make a beeline for that why is Street
Fighter in exhibit about Atari stop is
it and what you see here is actually Tom
I was looking on a deluxe edition three
fighter much like gotcha was originally
not with that the traditional the six
buttons that we know it had these two
really big buttons for punching and
kicking and he'd have to like slam
running harder to make your punches
harder in the game right exactly and one
of the things that always happen with
games too is will the game survive
Capcom encouraged people like oh you hit
it harder your punches are stronger as
people started like drop-kicking it to
see if it made it even stronger than
that yeah exactly
I'm down here in the lab I have
discovered some incredible stuff that is
in their archives and here are some of
the best things that I found this is the
bedroom I wanted to have when I was like
12 years old it's quite a few and it's
nice to have them going back three deep
but going back into the shelves yoji's
you're absolutely right they do let's go
look at some video games so we've got
the the Famicom disk system that was
never released over here and we've got
Mario - when it came over here Nintendo
of America said you know what I think
that's a little too hard for American
audiences so they took this game this
you make Hojo doki doki panick and they
reskin it all with with mario sprites
and so
when American audiences were playing
Super Mario Brothers 2 they were
actually playing this Doki Doki Panic
game instead
I liked Doki Doki Panic / maro USA a lot
better than I like the original these
are some of the rarest ones in the
collection that is the most expensive
rarest Hugh card variants are what is it
all star power League yep
all star our league now does that have
the little instruction sheet with it cuz
it came a little instruction it does
oh this tiny piece of paper here
increases the value of that game like
double yeah sorry just I'm forgetting to
say things because I'm so interested in
just looking at everything that's on the
shelves hey guys what video game do you
think belongs in a museum
let us know in the comments and then
subscribe Wired's youtube channel for
more game life videos